Comcast this already annoying logo which
I'm going to go ahead and give five
since four introduces the first fart
joke in under a minute of the movie's
runtime the rule book states that if a
joke of this nature occurs in under a
minute then the movie shall be levy to
fart tax of ten more since what it all
came to an end in season three so did
Balthazar go into puberty just now on
the show and they continue filling
leading us all to wonder where is he now
this leads me to wonder who's watching
this hardcopy show why is this the
format they used for Balthazar's
backstory if we're just gonna cut to the
present day version playing a villain on
TV was fun but being one in real life is
even better Trey Parker voices a
character in a despicable Me movie and I
couldn't be more shocked if they
announced the bass ketball - also boasts
position or is it boats position I mean
I guess it's boats position also also
introducing Balthazar breath a character
that seems entirely inspired by Peter
Dinklage's character and pixels which
was based on Billy Mitchell from the
king of Kong but mostly the pixels thing
because it sucks
[Music]
Balthazar made a mixtape that has love
songs on one side and heist music on
another I know this is a cartoon but who
does that also when Clive flips over the
tape he flips it at 180 degrees right to
left making this cassette player nah
impossible
[Music]
this is a terrible movie but it's even
worse when you realize that a
significant portion of the budget was
used to get the rights to a Michael
Jackson song even if Balthazar is the
sneakiest character in the world his
speedboat should have already announced
his presence to these two ships even if
the lookout is only concerned with
looking in one direction
nice try at pettiness illumination but
you can really only start throwing shade
after you've made something as good as
Finding Nemo any explanation given for
how the convenient weaponized bubblegum
works no god this movie already and it
hasn't even been five minutes
Silas sounded the alarm about the heist
after it was ongoing and Balthazar just
got the diamond so how'd it grew and
Lucie get here so fast
were they just out riding around in
their torpedoes for fun in the exact
location as the ship with the time and
she's getting away what do you think
this is really the faster form of
transportation why didn't they ride
these fuckers the entire time so cute
this girl who thinks the minions are
cute must have missed out on all the
assholes in the world using these
fuckers as teeth grinding memes for the
last seven years you'd think after just
one time having a weapon knocked out of
these guys hands they'd stop standing so
close to each other but that would ruin
whatever gag this is supposed to be
crudité Jesus Christ in the first seven
minutes alone they've packed in at least
seven thousand five hundred and thirty
four 80s references can't wait til they
get to the slap bracelets in act 2 funny
bit
but if bruised this close to the window
that means this building is currently
being destroyed by the floating ship so
are these beach babes actually gonna
these minions I mean I'm not judging I
just want to know how that's supposed to
work and if they have the proper
protection against mini eights no one on
this beach either noticed or cared that
a giant freighter floating above their
heads is being boarded by heavily armed
government agents there must be some
awesome moly available at the speech I
even bother with the subterfuge of
disguising the entrance to the
headquarters if the transport occurs out
in the wide open as everyone in this
universe and capable of looking up what
tried a few losers as agent Groh valery
enacted her hostile takeover of the AVL
and was promoted from the head office
but she doesn't know who congruous
either from his villain or hero days oh
the girls who apparently don't aged over
the course of seven years of movies how
could you let Balthasar brat the AVL's
most-wanted villain
just get away wait Balthazar is the
AVL's most wanted villain so why didn't
you send I mean I want every agent in
the area Silas told everyone in the area
to go there but how is that only GRU and
Lucy are they based in Miami this highly
secretive agency feels the best way to
fire their agents is to throw them out
in the clear view of the public today
Lucy and I were invited do not work
anymore what's the problem though sure
the agency's probably provided some good
benefits but GRU was independently
wealthy even after he stopped being a
villain in the last movie does let's not
go over to Kade this house and crew
still has minions and a ton of weaponry
but bands the kids from being exposed to
the real evil like pokerstars.com
also you knew this highlight reel of
good GRU and evil GRU couldn't go
without at least two jokes
leisa me labo Pomodoro Tom quit over two
movies GRU hasn't said in minionese but
all of a sudden he breaks that out here
on the surface of an unfunny joke Mel's
trying to Norma Rae the minions here but
if they're so fixated on villainy why
didn't they strike during the last movie
when they had the exact same
reservations in case you confused it
with Paris Sierra Leone that Chief of
Police sent me he was concerned that
during the recent highest attempt the
Dumont diamond was replaced with a phony
we find out later this is Balthazar in
disguise but seriously wouldn't a museum
have already conducted this test and
then wonder why the police chief is
telling a gem expert to go to the museum
unannounced I guess a villain needs to
make a dramatic escape in most instances
but can he just walk out the front door
he's sleep darted the entire museum
staff I was considering groot just
committed an extremely casual homicide
he may as well go back into full
villainy after you and your father were
born your father and I divorced and
someone was there to document the exact
moment you guys fell outta love decided
to divorce and separate the kids with a
short burst of Polaroids we each took
one son two ways on our own
and promised never to see each other
again and this agreement was totally
fine with him whatever laws were in
place at the time also why did drew wait
so long to contact group just because
their parents divorced it doesn't mean
he wasn't allowed to find him all this
time this is the family business the
largest peak farm in the whole of
Freedonia hard to believe the pig farms
still in business considering they just
leave these assholes anywhere on the
property including the runway no that's
my private part holy Sh like I decide so
hard I crack a rib it's almost like they
told Steve Carrel try and do something
more annoying than minions and this is
what happened after take 1 million 57 I
was my brother finding the wife like you
when he is so bald that's boldest screw
was super goddamn excited about meeting
his twin who's been nothing but nice to
his family but one crack about him being
bald immediately softened his brother
boner now you can be how the hell was
this show a hit even if brats considered
cool in the eighties he does a bunch of
evil right we're kids ready for the
antihero concept back then oh it's too
bad gruel won't be around to try and
stop me
how does brat know that GRU was fired
does he have an unexplained mole deep in
the AVL's HR department the pig farm was
just a cover for the real family
business
damn drew wasted no time in telling guru
about his sinister family background how
did he know grooms not still working for
the AVL GRU work for the AVL where
surely someone would have made mention
that his dad was a villain unless the
AVL simply erases all evidence of all
the villains they'd ever gone after even
though the front of the car is pointing
down during the fall this grappling-hook
shoots at the top of the cliff because
this franchise has a big meaty middle
finger for those of you who believe in
physics
go take a bite of his cheese young lady
just do it what's the worst that could
happen
Lucy encourages Margot to not only
approach strange foreign men but also to
eat whatever they have in their hands
when I bartender temporarily forgets
which eye he's lost I don't try and tell
me this is a subtle clue that he's
faking the one eye thing because this
movie is anything but subtle
steal candy yes please village cops
mobilize fast
were they staking that candy truck out
also if King candy truck isn't open
during the middle of the day what about
the festival that's happening nearby are
we saying these pigs can catch up to the
souped-up hotrod earlier I thought it
was amusing that evil brat was
outrunning the cops in his big wheel
because that's something an 80s kid show
might do but now I'm thinking this movie
believes non engine vehicles can compete
with cars but they just went through the
wall in the town right those cops were
relentless during this chase but just
gave up when they encountered a hole in
the ground sure everyone in the
supposedly realistic Southern California
city just ignore the army of cirrhosis
pills walking down the sidewalk man this
pizza delivery guide is never-ending
stack of pizzas that go past that
letterboxing you're telling me the
restaurant allows him to deliver pizzas
in a way that will cause lost inventory
and 75% of their profits
car required asshole so wait this poster
is advertising a show called sing but
it's not the movie that came out six
months before this one it's just another
thing called sing exclamation point
originality watch movie also if they are
related I want to see a universe where
Seth MacFarlane and Trey Parker have to
do a scene together especially after
that whole cartoon Wars thing a few
years ago the minions were able to walk
through the backstage production and
onto the stage of a currently filming
singing competition because we've
literally run out of situations to put
these little quads into also characters
running through a Hollywood studio find
themselves on sound stage during filming
and nobody thinks they're intruders
until it's way too late or a much dumber
cliche the scene is a humorous inside
joke because a pile of pink toilet paper
is exactly how the script was provided
to the cast is it just me or is there
something a bit off about this movie
they introduced a main antagonists like
Balthazar then go to another story
entirely with Gru's twin brother which
makes it seem like two different movies
were being made at the same time and
splice it together at the last minute of
course either I know this is played for
lamps but why did they pick Fritz to
constantly shit on in this movie does he
have a dark pass that we don't know
about
even though Drew's house is three times
as large as Cruz they still put the
girls in the same room together complete
with the dangerous triple bunk and a
ridiculous ladder no child should ever
climb it might not be good unicorn
finding weather oh yeah let's not forget
the C story in this movie
Agnes his attempt to find a unicorn I'm
beginning to wonder if they're going to
fit Sandman and venom into this thing
huh it's funny cuz its crew wait these
assholes were prosecuted for walking
onto the studio lot and convicted within
hours goddamn I thought this movie was
just going to be silly and annoying like
the other two despicable Me's but this
genuinely sucks
I've never seen a movie this short waste
so much time also man but sure are funny
aren't they
you've stopped your movie with stupid
little fucking animated banana Tic Tacs
just slap a butt on there an instant
comedy fuckin goal
cue movie there was no emotional
connection between GRU and the minions
before now and he certainly was never
shown taking any of them fishing also
according to this shot we've got roughly
five minutes before the earth is
swallowed by the Sun when the movie told
us that Agnes was going to seek out a
unicorn in the forest I thought that
meant with adult supervision
Lucy flipped out earlier when they
disappeared but I guess walking alone
into a forest that a one-eyed bartender
told you a unicorn lives in is perfectly
okay yeah no seriously how many
unnecessary subplots are there in this
movie that's mostly about the rivalry
between GRU and Pratt
Margot still hanging out with the dude
that gave of the cheese will Edith
continue her torturous pursuit of Fritz
well the few minions ever do anything
entertaining okay this is Brad's lair
wait I thought earlier it was a big deal
that he escaped because well you didn't
know where he would go after escaping
but you know where his lair is and the
AVL is a well-funded organization
committed to stopping villains so I
don't see the problem
even if his lair was considered
impenetrable you're about to do this job
with two people it may not look like
much but this place is armed with some
of the most high-tech weaponry known to
man how is it that Brett developed all
this evil tech by himself it's not like
his character was described as a super
genius he was just a failed child star
and even though he probably had some
scratch from evil Brett it only lasted
less than three seasons so the fact that
he's enormous ly wealthy is also some
bull oh damn I didn't realize Harvey
Weinstein had a son that lived in
Freedonia Oh mija mija how stupid is
this movie wait is brat Slayer seriously
with an easy boating distance of
Freedonia it's styled as a European
country and GRU lives in California so
where are we
I miss dominions I don't quick
camouflage ball I was he able to go into
camouflage mode and stay in sticky mode
when we saw GRU going through the
options it seemed pretty clear that you
could only pick one mode if you could do
both then why even bother doing this
mission without it even though the
Rockets are pointed specifically at drew
the scanning device has a flair for the
dramatic Lance starts on the other side
of the wall
manney sticky suit pure only sticky when
the plots demands him to be also grew
made the plan to break into Brandt's
lair before he even knew the suits
existed so how the hell did he think he
would get in this plan is highly
dependent on these suits well it looks
like someone's been reading the comic
guru drop and finally got to the section
on Grusin ining Balthazar's layer is
impenetrable except if you want to burn
a hole around an AC unit wow the minions
have been committed to this escape plan
considering this little guy is being
actively flown what kind of air
conditioning unit has a panel connected
to a carpeted floor
drew and GRU just happen to be here at
the exact time brat set his alarm to put
his evil plan into action also this
could have been a good time to turn on
that camouflage feature of these suits
after getting shot in the eye with this
laser causes tinnitus because the
writers have clearly lost control of
their senses not only did brat have all
these dolls programmed to kill he had
them all in boxes able to be
synchronized to voice commands keep in
mind that this technological genius
still watches VHS tapes
[Music]
Lucey ex machina but how did she know
they were here and what did she think
she was gonna do in this helicopter
didn't GRU tell her that this lair was
impenetrable and had a defense system
that would shoot missiles at anyone who
got close to the AVL and get the jobs
back yeah but GRU already had the
diamond after the last encounter with
brat it was the fact that he couldn't
catch him that got him fired
so this plan was faulty from the start
minions singing 99 bottles of beer on
the wall is a new chalkboard scratching
standard for the despicable me franchise
you there's so much kind of plain has a
chain lock now that's what I call acting
even if I believe Balthazar could
disguise himself exactly like Lucy I can
never believe he imitated her voice so
perfectly also this reveal is one of the
most brain twisting logic problems we've
ever encountered in a movie how did he
even get here especially this fast I
guess he could have been disguised as
Lucy here when Lucy saved them from the
spikes but I'd ask why bother and if he
used a helicopter from his own lair
there should have been another
helicopter waiting at Drew's mansion
when they landed because the idea that
he could have flown to Drew's stole his
helicopter and back to his own lair in
time as monumentally silly especially
since he didn't know drew existed five
minutes ago the plane they're currently
in is the same plane grew in his family
arrived on so he didn't use that to get
here so what the movie I mean even more
bullshit right
I guess if Balthazar snuck in
overpowered Lucy and stole her identity
she could assume he took the girls but
there's no way of knowing that since she
was tied up in the closet the whole time
so were the minions flying to Freedonia
but they didn't know that's where GRU
and company are goddamn this movie has
no sense of where people and creatures
are okay so how the fuck did GRU know
where Balthazar would remember Balthazar
took off Andrews plane then showed up to
Hollywood inside a giant evil brat which
means he had to go back to his lair to
get that then he spent the rest of the
time underwater from wherever his lair
is to Hollywood and crew should have no
idea where he was also where the fuck
are things in this world they go from
Miami to Freedonia to Hollywood to
wherever the fuck they want like it's a
trip to the local grocery store he's
going to whole city and set it up with
his face I saw this episode too it was
called age of Ultron people taking
selfies in front of really dangerous
cliche wait I thought this bubble gum
was sticky so Lucy should be going
absolutely nowhere in this scene all
these missiles make a direct hit on the
giant robot which must have all been set
to mildly inconvenience brat fell from
his perch by the Hollywood sign so how
is he able to continue to laser this
circle he's basically at sea level
oh good guess but how does GRU know that
this was Drew's doing he passed out from
the fall before drew even got close to
the robot when archaeologists dig up the
sedimentary layer were all buried under
ten thousand years from now they're
going to find way too many movies from
this era that somehow end with the
humorous dance fight great I went
through this whole movie just to see a
vill
being carried away by a giant bubble
long hanging from his ball sack I'm back
on the job
no villainy tonight movie had time to
show us a minion prison montage but has
no time to show us how GRU and Lucy got
their jobs back well that's not waking
anyone else in the neighborhood up
through an unappealing character from
start to finish is supposed to be the
villain in Despicable Me 4 count me out
would you like some of my cheese it's
like you're dreaming about gorgonzola
cheese when it's clearly brie time baby
[Music]
you with me to confirm my engagement to
your doctor with all respect you got
fired no no no no that guy look God that
guy Luke it's your turn
[Music]
[Applause]
brick kill the guy